hello everybody first of all thank you
for your time in advance
it's a pleasure to be here and to open
the first pi data helsinki
uh conference and meetup
um i would quickly share my screen
all right so my name is osan gentrolo
i'm co-founder and head of ai at top
data science leading about
20 data scientists at top data science
we are
we are a helsinki based ai consultancy
and we solve our clients problems with
machine learning and today i'll be
talking about
uh best practices of data augmentation i
will be talking about
of course first what data augmentation
is if you if you are not familiar with
that
and i'll be giving several examples of
data augmentation in various domains
such as computer vision natural language
processing
etc so my outline will be as such
first i'll introduce data augmentation
and the
scientific rationale behind it uh i'll
give a couple of remarks that is kind of
generic to
whatever data augmentation you are
performing and i will
right away dive into best practices i'll
give
examples from computer vision what is
the state of the art
what you should be actually be aware of
what you should be careful of similarly
in nlp
i will be mentioning a couple of cool
tricks in that
in that domain and some some examples
and libraries in
in a couple of other let's say
modalities such as time series or
tabular data
and then i will give couple of a bit
more advanced maybe use cases of data
augmentation
uh in in research as well as in the
industry
so i play factual meaning that i
give i try to give references scientific
references when i when i claim something
so if you see this green box
somewhere down any slide it means uh
that is the reference publication you
can you can go further have a read on
and if you see a red box uh it means
it's a it's a library
for for this for this uh meetup i
focused only on python so it
in in red boxes i will give to the
python library that you can perform
you can apply those things told in that
slide
so this is kind of the structure of of
my slides
okay so let's right away dive into data
augmentation
meanwhile you can write your questions
or comments in the chat part because we
will have a question and answering
session
so that you don't forget so data
augmentation is basically
um increasing your training data size by
diversifying your data i would like you
to
focus on the diversifying your data
training data more than increasing the
training size part
i will elaborate a bit more on that but
basically
uh if if if you if you have run
any kind of data science or machine
learning projects every company has
at least one person whatever you present
saying that just collect more data and
this
is this is where i believe data
augmentation originated from because
we data scientists we would like to we
would like to get the work
done uh without actually doing
too much hassle so we want to get the
job done
without doing the work so we of course
obviously
thought that how can we simulate uh
sampling from real real data
distribution so
something from nature meaning collecting
data
programmatically in a in a synthetic
way partly automatically
so data augmentation means that
basically
introducing some noise some
perturbations small changes
to your training data so that you
increase the diversity of your data
which helps in in several aspects so
the scientific rationale is uh
this talk is is a bit a bit focused on
neural networks and deep learning but
many of thing many of the things are
also generic
but from from a neural network's
perspective
neural networks are universal function
approximators
uh universal approximation theorem
meaning that
you can basically fit any function
perfectly meaning that you can actually
achieve
zero training or error uh with even
single layer neural network you don't
need a deep neural network
which is quite bad because we don't want
zero training error or it doesn't mean
that
we will generalize so these this kind of
methods and algorithms
machine learning models are very easy to
overfit and
by diversifying your data by
increasing your training data size you
make the model
uh you will give a hard time to the
model to overfit so actually
it serves as a regularization uh purpose
actually
and uh a bit
this is i'm not going into details but
uh
the choice of data augmentation should
in general
uh be taken care of depending on your
data arc neural network architecture
for example let's say convolutional
neural networks they are
translation equivalent meaning that an
object on the left of the image
shouldn't matter if it's on the right or
left so if you translate an object in
the image
the the convolutional neural networks
should be able to
learn representation of those so maybe
translation
augmentation is not actually
it's a bit redundant made before
convolutional known that's
these kind of things and typically
state-of-the-art results are are
achieved
in in research with data augmentation so
it's been a really
common practice actually both during
time
as well as during inference time
which we call test time augmentation
which i have a slide about
so a couple of remarks
the focus as i said should be
diversifying the data
and it's it's not a new concept in a
sense that
um it's it's pretty much rooted in
sampling theory because
you are attracted sampling sample from a
distribution
hopefully resembling actual data
distribution in nature
and this is very important your data
augmentations
in optimally should should be domain and
task dependent
they are and you should make use of that
so domain expertise when you are
coming up with data specific custom data
augmentations is crucial
i will give examples about that so
if everything's all right i would i
would right away
dive into best practices first i will
talk
about best practices of generic data
augmentation
these things apply to computer vision uh
tabular data uh
natural language processing like text
text data etc
then i will further run down into that
kind of
modality specific augmentations so
the first thing i would like to
recommend is use the domain knowledge
when you select your augmentations or
implement a custom augmentation
so domain knowledge means the task at
hand
usually almost always have certain kind
of prior
information or prior knowledge that's
available to you or to the domain
experts and
it's quite important to make use of that
domain knowledge when you devise
basically your data augmentations for
example
um let's say you are building your
object detection model
or an image classification model etc and
you want to put this into production
where there there's a camera but
the camera stream you know you know that
the camera stream is giving you
let's say jpeg images jpeg is a com
lossy compression so it it actually
decreases the quality of the image
but your training data is all nice high
quality images
so what you should do is that using that
knowledge that hey this camera the
security camera or whatever is kind of
low quality and it's doing this
compression
i should augment my training data during
training time
with gpec compression it's it's an
augmentation technique
so that the training data statistical
distribution of the training data
resembles the statistical distribution
of the data
in production or test data if you if you
if you want to call that
second example let's say you are doing a
text classification
you have this text glycerol is a
whatever i just copied this from
wikipedia actually and the label is
biology this text is about biology or
chemistry
it can be and as a chemist or
or or as a as a biologist you also know
that glycerol has another name glycerine
or glycerin and you would like to add
these kind of
versions of the of your data as data
augmentation
so so that you use the domain knowledge
and
increase the diversity of your training
data this was an example from
from natural language processing
second best practice please augment
only the training data so we are we have
training
validation and holdout data so
test data if you call it uh we don't
wanna
we don't wanna augment the validation
data so we augment the training data
only uh this is this is i
i hope this this makes sense to you this
is quite important to to have
to have fair comparisons and uh
realistic estimation of errors actually
when you put things into production
all right continuing so randomness is
your friend
especially when you are training neural
networks
we like randomness or stochastic
stochasticity right
so uh neural network training is
is is is a non-comex optimization
problem
i will not go into details of this uh
meaning that it's np hard meaning that
you are you are not really actually
searching for
global minimum because it finding it is
pretty damn difficult so you are okay
with
local minima and the problem is
uh you get stuck there in local minima
or in saddle points
and mon there are several several like
this plethora of research that shows
that when you when you do for example
this batch gradient descent
uh so you randomly select certain batch
of data you don't like always give the
same
sequence of data you randomize things it
eases
for you to to generalize more you can
move from uh this kind of saddle points
or
local minima easier so this this is
from a data augmentation perspective it
helps your training and
generalization power when you when you
add more randomness so
make things more random which comes to
the practice of it
so please do not augment your data
and save it to a to your computer or to
a
database or hard drive and then train a
model
because um even though you introdu you
can introduce this
augmentation with a probabilistic way so
that it's random
it's also it's also like a kind of
fixed once you create those actually
augmented data
and also you you you actually use lots
of storage space
etc what we typically do is we augment
on the fly
while training a model so this is quite
a good practice
to have so on the fly you randomly
randomly some part of the data
is like transformed perturbed whatever
your augmentations is
some part of the observations some of
the observations are
augmented with certain probability with
certain augmentations so this kind of
randomness on the fly
that's a good that's a good practice
it's important to profile your training
so
typically data augmentations happens on
cpu
um and neural networks are you train
neural networks in
in gpu so usually you shouldn't have
speed bottlenecks because of
augmentations
because usually the heavy part of
training a model is
is happening on the gpu and
flipping images or stuff like that
shouldn't slow down your training
but but if you have a custom
augmentation with something
something very computationally heavy for
whatever reason you implemented this
it's important for your domain let's say
uh
it may slow down actually your training
so
also realize that some augmentations can
be actually
done on gpu and i i believe this is kind
of the pathway
where where we are heading actually in
the in the industry and in the research
so profiling the speed of your training
uh turning on
on and off the augmentations to see if
it makes sense
it's a good practice now
i get lots of questions that okay
which data augmentations to choose and
their probabilities
aren't they hyper parameters technically
yes so
uh which data type of data augmentation
it's a
it's a categorical hyper parameter if
you
you can choose from 10 like you can turn
on and off each so you have 10 hyper
parameters
then each augmentation let's say the
strength of
rotation or how much you want to rotate
the angle that's a parameter of the
uh kind of augmentation itself
uh then you if you wanna assign separate
proper
different probabilities to each
augmentation so this thing
explodes right so you don't wanna
do some hyper parameter optimization on
every single this probability of this
augmentation should be optimal we don't
have that much time and computation
power
so kind of kind of simplify
things right so group group maybe type
of augmentations for example from
image or computer region rotation
shifting
a fine transform or scaling group them
into geometric transformation category
maybe so they are happening together
um set the probability of each
augmentation
to a single value maybe maybe you don't
want to
have 0.2 for this 0.35 for this so
it really explodes your search space so
keep it simple uh play with the
probability of
you want to augment this sample with or
not
play with that kind of strength of
augmentation
this is kind of a way to simplify this
whole data augmentation
parameter tuning if you if you want to
call it
and finally always visualize this is
like
one of the most important things before
training
always visualize inspect manually does
these
augmentations make sense uh look at your
images
augmented images look at your augmented
text
videos etc because you don't want to
mess up your training
they should make sense this is quite
important
all right let's dive into computer
vision so
very typical augmentations is changing
the shuffling to color space
a fine transform or this kind of
inverting the
inverting the actually color space you
can play with exposure so lighting
lighting of the image you can rotate uh
and you can change the alpha channel etc
these are
these are pretty typical augmentations
you can add some noise
uh salt and pepper noise or other kinds
of blur
uh motion blur you can add some domain
specific
augmentations as well something
something
or jpeg compression this kind of
compression augmentations
something uh i really would like to
recommend is this albumentations library
i use it quite a lot with my team uh of
course tensorflow pytorch other
libraries have all
their their internal internal let's say
uh
data augmentation let's say
functionalities
but augmentations is is a
well-documented
uh well-growing library that has many
many different
augmentations image augmentations in it
so
feel free to check it out the current
state of the art in computer region
kind of peer-reviewed and published is
uh
mix-up cut out and cut mixed
augmentations
so in mix-up you actually would like to
mix
several for for image classification
right some
several several classes together like
you have your cat and the dog together
cut out you actually
simply cut out a huge portion of of of
the
of the image and cut mix is actually you
put
put an image from or a portion from
from another class into it so feel free
to also check these
check these if you if you want to try
this out
now i would like to emphasize if you're
if you have volumetric data so 3d data
for example medical images like mr
ct it's it's it's kind of slices of
2d images meaning that you have a 3d
structure
uh you should be careful when you are
augmenting each slice actually you
shouldn't
you shouldn't do that because uh one
slice here
is augmented with this augmentation and
the second slice is perturbed with
another augmentation
you kind of you kind of lose the whole
3d structure right
so instead use torch torch io
uh i don't know if it's pronounced like
that a library
which actually if you watch watch
carefully this is a movie
like a in in in this slide
you can actually modify the modify
the whole whole data with
in a 3d manner without losing the 3d
shape so this is a cool library
and similarly for video you wanna you
wanna apply
data augmentation to each frame the same
augmentation to each frame of the video
so that
you don't lose the you don't lose the
logic there
let's talk about nlp so you can have
character level augmentations so you can
for example
insert some characters delete some
characters or simulate keyboard errors
for typing error you can have word level
augmentations
you can substitute some synonyms this is
pretty common
you can use another actually pre-trained
model to insert some contextual words
something like birth for example you can
swap or delete words
or you can have sentence level
augmentations you can insert sentences
using a
uh gpt2 kind of models you can shuffle
sentences
uh you can create this kind of diversity
you can increase your training data size
with these kind of tricks
and nlp oak is the library i i used
couple of times
it's quite nice uh for for for nlp
augmentations
an example here for example if the
original sentences
sentence is said superior human comedy
played out on the back roads of life
you can change sad with a synonym
lamentable you can randomly insert some
words swap some words or delete some
words
just just an illustration of how how
these things work
all right so one another
trick in in nlp is back translation so
you can
translate your english into for example
french and
back translate to english this gives
some kind of variation
which is used nowadays quite a lot and
for
time series tabular and audio data there
are several libraries delta pi
ct gun these are for for tabular data
for example ct gun trains the generative
model
generate generate adversarial network
out of your
out of your tabular data and then you
can sample actually
uh from that distribution to generate
to augment uh tabular data
audiomentations
you can use it to to augment audio data
and i have a couple of slides left uh
only
a couple of other use cases uh test time
augmentation if you see in a paper tta
it means test time augmentation meaning
that during inference during prediction
time
you would you can actually boost your
model performance for example
you can you can pass through your model
you can predict
several versions of the images augmented
versions of your image
or your text and get your predictions
and do some ensemble
maybe you can do majority voting or
check the most pick the one that is most
confident or do some
averaging of the probabilities etc so
this usually
test time augmentation usually boosts
boost up your
let's say model performance a couple of
percent so if you want to squeeze the
most out of
everything go go ahead and apply
obviously there's no free lunch so uh
the downside is that you need to
infer you need to predict all those
three for example augmentations
meaning that you need to run predictions
three times
so your results will be you need to wait
three times more so it will be slower
then uh some some recent papers actually
published
turn this into a meta learning problem
so
trying to learn what is the best
augmentation for
for for a given task so
using for example reinforcement learning
this is a bit falling into auto ml
automated machine learning
like craze so for example uh
this this paper the last paper in the
references
it actually learns which range for
reinforcement learning
like the best combination of
augmentations for that specific task so
you can do
if you have enough computation power you
don't even have to define
those augmentation combinations but you
can actually make the neural network
learn or the model learn
those things and some interesting ideas
is that
we augment always in the raw data
original data space but
you can actually augment on the latent
space latent space meaning that
on the representation space so this is
an interesting
idea that you can extrapolate
interpolate add some noise on the
earned representation space like feature
space
and augmented data there this this is
this is an interesting idea
and finally ai models propagate
or even reinforce social biases for
example
pick any language model actually it's a
couple of lines of code
and you can perform this masked word
prediction so
just mask a word and make the model
predict that word
and if you for example have such a
sentence if you predict what
what is the probabilities of words
coming
instead of the mask and he is an
engineer
with the probability 79 and
she it has much less probability you
will see there are
hundreds of papers written about this
bias in
in in ai models and other words have
maybe law even lower probabilities but
this is obviously
kind of a bias a social biased kind of
injected into the ai model and you can
use
data augmentation so you can replace
he's and she's
so you can make things more fair more
balanced in your training data
to to to kind of counteract this uh uh
bias in in ai models so that was it from
me
i hope you enjoyed it i hope you learned
something it was my pleasure and i would
be happy to answer your questions
as much as i can thank you very much
all right thank you so much augustine
that was really interesting
yeah actually we have couple of
questions in the chat
i can read some of them so first
question from
he or she asked about where is the data
stored
and what format is it stored in is it
variably the same size as the actual
image
yeah actually uh as i mentioned we don't
want to store
we don't want to store the augmented
data so you you have your data
it's stored somewhere wherever your your
system is in
in your computer in the database uh
we wanna apply augmentations like
perturbations
changes on the fly during the neural
network training so we don't save those
actually
so during the model training we would
like to
apply apply those changes and the model
learns from those so
typically we don't wanna we don't wanna
save those augmentations
all right i guess that's that's clear so
another question from
xenia he or she asked about
when when we are talking about state of
the art in data augmentation
what exactly does it mean uh it's a bit
uh kind of to how
how machine learning research is done i
don't want to go into that discussion is
but uh we have well-known let's say data
sets for example
uh coco imagenet etc for image
classification
object detection image segmentation
semantic segmentation all these
computer vision tasks and uh
typically state of the art means that
having everything else equal
meaning the same neural network
architecture same training parameters
learning rate etc
uh they change the augmentation type
and test which one performs better
so that's what i meant those new
augmentations
i introduced were the ones that
performed more
the better better than others uh so
one comment can be is that is this a
fair comparison because when you change
the
change the data augmentation and maybe
even the
probabilities the neural network
parameters
you should change maybe the learning
rate etc so
um this is i'm just like kind of stating
what is what has been used if you want
to choose
a couple of good augmentations it was
mix-up cut mix
and similar augmentations uh currently
used
all right thanks so
maria is asking when dealing with
smaller language
groups like finnish swedish how would
you augment content
with nlp
so some of the nlp augmentations i
mentioned
they can be applied to to to any
language meaning that
you can swap images you can delete
swap words characters delete them
you can swap the sentences insert
characters but for finnish language
specific for example you can use a word
stammer finnish word stammer
and change the suffix because finnish is
such a word that
such a language that you have lots of
versions of
of a noun uh like
etc so you can play with that by just
stemming
stemming those words or you can use a
for example multilingual
uh language model such as uh
multilingual birth
to insert some some words that actually
make sense when you read the sense of
sentences like contextual contextualized
word representations
or you can use actually a language model
trained
on finnish language for example i think
turku university or robo academy has a
finnish birth
so you can use even finnish
insertions uh or deletion in like this
kind of
contextual word or language sentence
insertions
uh that's what i would do and you can
always do back translation translate to
english and back to finnish
uh i don't know if if there's any
machine translation model for that
though
yeah all right so another question from
tommaso he's asking
how much data augmentation is too much
especially in the nlp
i imagine that too much augmentation
would eventually distort
the meaning of the sentence that's
correct that's that's for sure there's
there's a
there's such a point that you actually
distort the image so much that
it's it's completely from a different uh
sampled from a different statistical
distribution
in computer vision or nlp that's a fact
so uh i i don't have an answer because
that's the domain specific so problem
specific thing
uh but the cool thing i introduced is
that you you keep
the probabilities of each augmentations
fixed
and just play with the if you just play
with the
probability this one hyper parameter the
augment this
this sample or not and just sweep it a
bit
uh but play around with that a bit you
will see
more or less a cutoff point that is too
much
so do not over engineer that play with
each probability of each augmentation
because then
then that's that's like a huge thing uh
computation wise
so uh with with couple of trainings you
you will actually have
a more or less a cut point that okay
this much of probabilities
is okay for data augmentation
all right we have another question in
the context of
evaluating the data augmentation so
carreta is asking if there is some sort
of matrix that could
be used as a guideline to evaluate the
quality of data augmentation
um typically we we would like to
we emulate our whatever we do in our
choice of architecture choice of
parameters like our design choice of
algorithm
uh we will evaluate all that using a
validation set right validation data
so this is this is the same uh
it's better if you cross validate things
sure so basically it's the same that
that's why you never you don't touch the
validation data
you don't augment it you keep the same
validation data and try out different
augmentations or
augmentation use augmentation or not to
compare that
um now there's one recent paper
that actually it's a bit advanced but
they
they actually try to find such a subset
of data that
if you try the augmentations on that it
will generalize
the performance of that augmentations
like this is better or this is better
that knowledge will generalize to the
whole data set
so you run you can run lots of trainings
because it's a small subset of data
but they turn that into a learning
problem itself
you might want to check that out
all right okay so i guess the last
question would be
so it's from andrea and
uh it looks like data augmentation might
also be used to add a bias within the
data
is it possible in your opinion
yeah that's possible you should be
careful about that
yeah the the thing the thing about bias
or fair fairness this fairness concept
so uh there are several fairness metrics
that that we can use to to uh to
basically
evaluate how fair two model two models
are
and uh the bummer is that uh
it's mathematically impossible to to
actually comply with
all those fairness co fairness let's say
metrics
or constraints simultaneously so
um it's kind of a pareto thing that once
if you are
if you make your model fair in some
sense it becomes unfair
more unfair in in another sense uh
if you can email me i can send you the
paper that proves that actually
all right sounds good yeah i think we
can take
one last question so maxim is asking
if you have any thoughts on
pseudo-labeling techniques
that is quite relevant with the current
research also
uh thanks for asking that i i didn't
want to go into that
because there's no time so this whole
pseudo labeling or self supervision
uh it's it's quite important
with the data augmentation simply
because
uh you you i i'm not going i don't have
time to go
explain what self-supervised let's say
pre-training is but
so uh for for people who don't know that
instead of creating annotating
a lot of data you want to use a weaker
model
uh basically to pseudo label so
you predict the labels of your
unannotated data and train
with those labels so you constantly
iteratively increase the
uh training size actually and
a couple of errors there and there it
it's okay so this is the logic there
and this is pseudo labeling
i haven't used pseudo labeling and
data augmentation in an industrial
project
that is in actually in production but
it's something i would like to
i would like to actually also experiment
with because
i would definitely use data augmentation
in there
all right sounds great thank you so much
ogojan that was really thank you very
much